foreign
[Music]
was the last truly [__] nasty nasty
bad pop girl
[Applause]
[Music]
the best job in the world
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
I like you
might I ask who are you
it's really like unlock something in me
she's had a tough year the Press has
been brutal annoying okay
it was a selfie yeah I mean it's kind of
it's like a she was on her [__] knees
pop music is like the ultimate Trojan
Horse
[Music]
people to dance to get people to sing
along come on give me more I want to be
the biggest touring act ever
a great [__] idea
I haven't seen no [__] like this since
the 90s
he's brainwasher I promise you there's a
new Jocelyn coming all right
hello angels
[Applause]
[Music]